The next question. Assalamu alaykum and
namaste Dr. Zark Nai. I recently watched
your lecture on the similarities of
Islam and Hinduism. It was so beautiful
and I am so impressed with your
knowledge on both religions and the
scriptures. I have one question if you
could please answer. In the lecture time
2 hours 32 minutes and 9 seconds, an
individual asked you that you have said
that there are so many similarities
between Islam and Hinduism. Does that
mean that according to Islam, a person
can be a Hindu? In response, you have
said that if you mean by the term Hindu,
a person who follows the religious
scriptures of Hinduism, then I have got
no objection as long as that Hindu
strictly follows the established truths
of the scriptures of Hinduism.
Established truths means those truths
mentioned in the Hindu scripture which
have been confirmed by the last and
final revelation of God that is the
glorious Quran and I'm referring to
Vedas and the Quran which are mentioned
in my lectures both of them they believe
that there is one God they believe in
the messengers they believe the last
messenger is prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him they believe in the hereafter
after if they believe in all these
established facts I have got no
objection mashallah the revert has
repeat man in detail mashallah if this
is exactly about a Hindu believes then
what makes them different from a Muslim
is the word religion just a term at the
point at this point can a Muslim and
Hindu get married if not then why not I
would really appreciate your answer on
this thank you in the ending the
question I suppose
that if she follows the truths or if
that Hindu follows the truth in the
Hindu scripture which is established by
the Quran and the Sai had meaning
if you follow those Hindu scriptures
which established by the teachings of
Quran and say then what is the
difference correct you're right if the
person follows the established teachings
in the Hindu scriptures which is
mentioned the Quran in say then he
become the Muslim. He has to become a
Muslim. He has to believe there's one
God. He has to believe prophet Muhammad
the last time final messenger of God.
And this is mentioned in the Hindu
scriptures and I've proven in my lecture
that even the Hindus believe in one true
God who has no image etc. And they
believe also that in the last and final
messenger prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him. And these two are the most
important criteria for anyone to accept
Islam. So my answer was very clearcut
that if they really a true practicing
Muslim based on the teachings of the
Hindu scriptures which match with the
Quran and they are Muslims. What is the
difference? The difference is that Hindu
as I mentioned in my talk is a
geographical definition. Those people
living in the land of the Indis Valley
civilization or those people living in
India they are called as Hindu. It's a
geographical definition. It is not a
religious definition. The right word
should be vant according to Swami Swami.
A person who follows the Vedas should be
called a vantist and not a Hindu. Hindu
is a misnomer. So in that context I am
from India. I have to live in India. I'm
a Hindu by geographical definition. But
the real Muslim is a person who submits
will to Allah subhana wa tala. So if a
person who believes in the Hindu
scriptures, they write the Quran and
they believe that there is one God and
they believe that prophet Muhammad is
the messenger of God. They are Muslims.
So they become Muslims and the right
word is Muslim. So inshallah we pray to
Allah subhananaa tala that may your
father and your mother and your brothers
and sisters inshallah they become
Muslims they they follow Allah and his
they worship only one god and though
there are many facility that is there
but if you believe in one god and
believe in the last and final revelation
of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala then you
are a Muslim you enter the fold of Islam
and according to you should not delay
because you don't know how long a person
will live. Whether you want to see
tomorrow or not, we don't know. So my
request to you would be do it and see to
it that you follow the Quran and the
hope that answers the question.